Let's go ahead and add the post() handler.
Okay, so here we are in our editor,
and we've got our get handler, and this is what draws the form.
Let's add the post version, and this will get called when we post to the URL,
which is what happens when we submit our form.
Okay,so I've added a post function that goes along with our get function,
and the post function will get called when we post to /, which is what our form does.
And upon a post, we will return back to the browser--
the string--"Thanks! That's a totally valid day!"
Alright, let's give that a shot in our browser.
Okay, so here we are in the browser. I've reloaded my page.
Now I'm going to type in some submissions, and this isn't exactly a valid month, day, and year,
but let's click submit.
Our form says, "Thanks! That's a totally valid day!" which is nice of it to say,
but our day isn't exactly valid, is it?